Listen carefully to
your teen and a lecture,
but waves of contempt
for existence itself.
Teak.
Tell me there's a part of me that
rebels and riding these waves waves,
but can I harness them for good God,
you guys,
you ask the hardest questions.
Waves of contempt of exists
for existence itself.
Keep coming.
Well,
I guess what I would say is
it's probably time for a little bit of
individual psychoanalysis and I don't
necessarily mean that you have
to go and find a therapist.
I would say
you're generalizing,
you know,
you say waves of contempt for
existence itself keep coming,
but I don't believe that that's exactly
right and I'm certainly not accusing you
of being deceitful.
It's,
it's more like low resolution.
My suspicions are is that there's a set
of experiences that you've had that are
characteristic to your own personal life,
that have caused you to do,
caused you some bitterness and some
resentment and that those haven't been
thought through.
And usually thinking through
means at least in some part,
trying to take as much
responsibility for those,
for altering the conditions under which
those things happen going forward into
the future as possible.
Like the purpose of memory is to stop
you from doing the same stupid things in
the future,
right?
That that's the purpose.
And so if you've had experiences that
have made you bitter and resentful or are
still engaged in experiences
that are doing that,
then you need to do a careful micro
analysis of what those are and see if you
can see if you can flip your
attitude in some matter.
You know,
I'm not saying this is easy,
but the first thing you can do is at
least figure out what those memories are.
And I might recommend trying to past
Autherine program because what the past
offering program does is ask you to
break your life up into six he parks and
then to identify the
emotionally significant
occurrences during each of those
epochs.
And you can kind of tell if something
needs work from a memory perspective,
if,
if it occurred more than
about 18 months ago.
And when you remember it,
it still causes like a wave of sadness
or anger or really any kind of negative
emotion because what that means is
that your brain is still targeting that
experience as threatening and unexplored
and what that means is that in some
sense,
part of you or a part of the that could
exist is still stuck in that memory
because you can go back and do a careful
causal analysis of the events that led
up to the unfortunate circumstance
and try to map out your role.
Even if your role is minor,
there's going to be things that you could
have done differently to avoid it and
that's what you need to
figure out for the future.
I would say you try to shed
all your personal resentment.
A part of that too is to not
not take things too personally.
You know,
like one of the advantages of developing
what I would regard as a mythologically
centered view of the cosmos
is that you understand that
the reason there's,
there's nothing personal about the fact
that terrible things happen to you.
I mean,
unless you're directly causally
involved as as it says,
I believe in the Old Testament rains
on the just and the unjust delight.
And you know,
there there are,
this is an existentialist motif.
The tragedy and difficulty and even the
confrontation with evil are built into
the structure of existence.
And it's not aimed at
you personally and it,
well,
as I said,
it may be the price that we
pay for existence itself.
You could say,
well that price is too high to pay,
but well,
as I mentioned,
if you start taking that way,
then you make everything much,
much worse.
It seems better to shoulder you're cross
voluntarily and stumble forward towards
the light.
That's,
that's the best strategy.
And I would say that that just
because it's the best strategy,
it doesn't even necessarily mean
that it's always going to work.
Like this is no optimistic scenario
like a dragon fight is no optimistic
scenario.
Confront the dragon and get the gold and
get the girl and bring it back to co to
share it with the community,
the gold.
And you know,
that sounds all well and good,
but after all it is a dragon and
many people get eaten by them.
So,
but the myth basically says,
well,
your best bet is to open your eyes
and speak the truth and look forward
forthright and confront
the things that are,
um,
the hydrants that are raising their
heads in their tentacles constantly to
frighten you and stop you
and to fight the tyranny of,
of,
of the social structure when,
when it's oppressing you unduly.
And,
and that's,
and that's what you have to do.
But I would say if,
if that contempt is their mountain,
that's really worth
digging into because that,
that would also be the source.
That would be the place where you discover
the union shadow because you would
discover that contempt is an
unbelievably destructive force.
Contempt is a particularly destructive
force and it would be useful for you to
try to think about,
you can use fantasy to do this.
It's like,
okay,
if you let that contempt manifest itself
fully in like a dream or a daydream
and,
and you let it go on a rampage,
like what,
what's the vision exactly?
I mean,
is it the destruction of the town?
Is the destruction of the country?
You want the entire world to blow up?
Like are there specific people that
you're angry at or maybe you're angry at
yourself,
like you need to figure out those waves
of contempt are unarticulated elements
of experience and they're
part of your shadow.
So can you harness them for good?
Well,
I think the more you
understand your dark urges,
the more likely you are to be able to
regulate and control the men to use them
as part of your power.
A person or authority,
let's say a person who has authority is
someone who's integrated the dangerous
parts of themselves,
and that's part of what gives
their words Gravitas and weight.
Um,
and so yes,
I think you could,
you could harness them for good.
It's,
and I think that's the right thing to do,
but it will involve a fair bit
and painful soul searching.